what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we're going to
be talking about the recent Fantastic
Four news about the writers about the
casting and we're also going to be
talking about whether or not Marvel
Studios is actually trolling us right
now I actually kind of think they are
but at the same time I do kind of think
this is a good thing as well and of
course I'll explain what I mean in this
video but we could be looking at some
bad news for those who wanted John
Krasinski to play the main Mr Fantastic
Reed Richards in the MCU not just the
one that got obliterated and literally
torn to shreds in Multiverse of Madness
unfortunately but also kind of
fortunately it has been established that
variants can look different from one
another key example is the three
different Spider-Man and of course Loki
and Sylvie and while that can be awesome
because we get awesome characters like
Sylvie like the other two Spider-Man it
also does mean that the same actor does
not necessarily have to play a different
variant of himself which means John
Krasinski doesn't have to play the main
MCU Reed Richards now of course many of
us I think the good majority of us were
expecting a Fantastic Four announcement
of some sort at d23 and while we did
kind of get one it was definitely not
what we were expecting they announced
that Mack shackman is going to be
directing the movie however due to some
reports that came out earlier that week
we already knew that but not too long
after d23 just a couple of days ago the
writers were announced for the Fantastic
Four
deadline.com reported that Jeff Kaplan
and Ian Springer are going to write the
new Fantastic Four film for Marvel
Studios Kevin feige the president of
Marvel Studios is of course producing
the film so they're going to be teaming
up with him and the new director Matt
shackman who directed One Division
however in deadline's article they say
something that is quite interesting in
their article they said at Disney's d23
event this month feige confirmed
shackman as director of the film but
said that was all he had for the
audience at the time with no cast on
board now this can be interpreted two
different ways some people have been
saying that this means that Marvel
Studios does not have a cast chosen yet
for the Fantastic Four while on the
other hand you could simply interpret
this as deadlines saying that they did
not announce a cast at d23 which is kind
of how I see it I do personally think
that Kevin feige has probably found his
cast for The Fantastic Four but sadly it
looks like John Krasinski might not be
be a part of that cast according to a
rumor from an apparent trusted source of
the Marvel Studios spoilers subreddit
monitors Marvel Studios is no longer
considering John Krasinski to play the
mcu's Reed Richards in the Fantastic
Four film and in fact they may not have
ever intended on John Krasinski to play
the main Mr Fantastic in the MCU it was
recently revealed by Doctor Strange 2
director Sam raymi that Kevin feige
basically put John Krasinski in there as
kind of a fun thing to do and kind of a
cool little Fan cast opportunity he said
in an interview it's so funny that Kevin
feige cast John Krasinski because the
fans had a dream of who the perfect Reed
Richards would be and because this is an
alternate universe I think Kevin said
let's make that dream come true I've
always really enjoyed all of his
performances so this statement combined
with the recent Marvel Studios spoilers
subreddit information makes us think
that John Krasinski probably isn't going
to be playing Mr Fantastic in the MCU as
far as we've heard and are concerned
right now Penn Badgley is still the top
front runner to play Mr Fantastic in the
MCU we'll get to that in a bit but first
we do actually have some new casting
rumors for The Invisible Woman Sue storm
and her brother in the comics the Human
Torch Johnny Storm according to a recent
post on their story from the official
account for Des Moines Alexandra
Daddario and her brother Matthew
Daddario are in talks to play Sue storm
in the Fantastic Four and I'm assuming
since their brother and sister her
brother is up for the brother in the
movie Johnny Storm now real quick before
we dive into these two choices if you're
not familiar with the Moy all of their
Scoops and things that they report are
basically sent in by users they have
been incredibly accurate in the past but
they've also been wrong about a lot as
well so take this with a grain of salt
this is definitely not confirmed but
let's talk about Alexandra and Matthew
for the roles of Sue storm and Johnny
Storm now I know some people are going
to say she's not blonde well neither is
Jessica Alba but she was blind for the
movie she can bleach her hair blonde or
wear wig it's not that big of a deal the
question is would she make a good
invisible woman now as far as her acting
goes she's a great actress I've seen
many films and TV shows with her in it
and she can play funny roles but she can
also play very serious roles as well
which I think is something that you
actually need for the Fantastic Four
specifically set in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe where we know that comedy is a
thing and especially if the Seth Rogen
as the thing rumors are true we're
definitely going to need somebody who
can do comedy and as far as the look is
concerned I think easily she could play
Sue storm again just change her hair to
blonde now as far as her brother Matthew
is concerned I actually don't know that
much about him now he is an actor of
course he's been in many things and I do
really like this idea of actually
casting siblings for the role of
siblings in the MCU now obviously when
you cast actors who have a great track
record who are amazing actors and who
have done great projects they can act
like they are actually siblings with
somebody but I do think there is a
certain chemistry that comes with
actually being brother and sister which
is why I'm actually okay with this and
as far as the look of Johnny Storm I
definitely think that Matthew could pull
off a Johnny Storm now having said that
I do think there are probably better
choices for Sue and Johnny Storm
specifically the names who were on a
casting list that was revealed by some
insiders and we've heard a lot of names
thrown out there so far for the
Invisible Woman Mr Fantastic the Human
Torch and the thing and that actually
brings me to my next point which I
mentioned in the beginning the question
of is Marvel kind of trolling us right
now there have been so many names thrown
out there recently for the casting of
the Fantastic Four I'm starting to think
it's very intentional multiple insiders
said that Marvel Studios was going to
reveal the cast of The Fantastic Four at
d23 but of course they didn't perhaps
they were going to but then changed
their mind or perhaps they kind of
leaked information out there that was
false on purpose because if you think
about it it actually makes sense Marvel
knows what happens online on Twitter on
Instagram on YouTube on Reddit and I can
personally tell you that I know marvel
sees everything and if you're Marvel and
you're trying to keep a movie or casting
for a movie a secret I think one of the
best things that you can do is to
intentionally spread misinformation to
protect the real info this would
definitely work especially if the real
info was actually already out there you
could saturate it by putting out other
names for other actors for the role I
think this is a real possibility however
having said that the deadline report
states that the writers have been
attached to the project for a while now
and we know that Kevin feige was talking
about and mentioned the Fantastic Four
all the way back in 2019 at San Diego
Comic-Con so I assume he knows who he
wants to play The Fantastic Four and
they probably have already been cast and
if not I think they are right on the
verge of being cast and remember this is
Kevin feige's baby it's his love project
he's been thinking about this for a very
long time probably even before or right
around the time when they got the rights
back to the Fantastic Four we know that
he met with Taryn egerton talked to him
about playing Cyclops years ago right
around the time where the fox Disney
deal went through Kevin feige is a
planner and he thinks about things years
and years in advance so no doubt Kevin
feige doesn't want the casting info to
get out until he says it's time and
until then could Marvel Studios perhaps
be put in some false information out
there to make it to where we really
don't know who the cast of The Fantastic
Four is yeah it's a possibility but I
still do believe that the truth is out
there because people talk and insiders
find out this information from people on
the inside hey at the end of the day it
could be John Krasinski and his wife
Emily Blunt or it could be Alex Daddario
and her brother but right now based off
of what we've heard recently it still
looks like pin badge actually is still
the front runner to play Mr Fantastic in
the MCU and it also looks like Jody
Comer who has already worked with Disney
and fox since Disney owns Fox and she
worked with them on free guy has
probably locked down a role with Marvel
Studios already presumably for The
Invisible Woman those two seem to be our
Front Runners right now but of course
only time will tell I have a hunch just
a feeling not any type of Insider
information or anything but just a
feeling that Kevin feige might make us
wait until next year's San Diego
Comic-Con 2 actually revealed the
official cast for The Fantastic Four I
hope I'm wrong I hope we don't have to
wait that long but we'll see and of
course if I hear anything regarding the
Fantastic forecasting news or anything
else I'll be sure to update you with a
video so be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification Bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos don't
forget to like the video and of course
for live updates you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof